onald Trump. Once again, as he often does,
gave one of these strange teleprompter sort
of coma speeches where he looks visibly confused
by the words on the prompter, which by the
way, still doesn't keep him on message and
jumped directly on the Republican bandwagon
of the last 48 hours of blaming video games
for violence in the real world. I played clips
for you yesterday from Fox News, Texas, Lieutenant
Governor and a Republican Congressman Kevin
McCarthy, blaming video games for shootings,
blaming the violence within those games for
making people go out and commit shootings
in the real world. And I told you yesterday
they are United behind this talking point
because they don't want to take responsibility
or acknowledge Donald Trump's own rhetoric
and their fearmongering about immigrants for
a year after year after year for being at
least partially responsible for shootings
and violent acts that we've seen of late here
is Donald Trump jumping on the bandwagon,
bringing on bringing up video games.
Second, we must stop the glorification of
violence in our society. This includes the
gruesome and grizzly video games that are
now commonplace. It is too easy today for
troubled youth to surround themselves with
a culture that celebrates violence. We must
stop or substantially reduce this and it has
to begin immediately.
Ethan Klein from the age three podcast reminded
us of this clip, which is just one example
and this one, Donald Trump joking and, and
sort of playing around with the idea of violence
against immigrants to stop them from coming
to the United States. Check out this clip
and there are many of these,
but how do you stop these people? You can't
fish. No
[inaudible] Jolie in the panhandle. You can
get away with that. [inaudible] in the,
that type of thing is far more responsible
for real world violence than video games.
We know this and before we get back to the
main topic here, Donald Trump also mistakenly
referring to to the Toledo shooting yesterday
instead of Dayton. Uh, the shooting of code
of course was not until Edo it was in Dayton.
And you'll notice in this clip, Trump strange
sniffing his back, his mush mouth speech is
back. There's something very odd about this.
If we are able to pass great legislation.
After all of these years, we will ensure that
those who were attacked will not have died
in vain. May God bless the memory of those
who perished in Toledo and may God protect
them, make God protect all of those from Texas
to Ohio. May God bless the victims and their
families. Make God bless America. Thank you
very much. Thank you.
[inaudible]
weird that this happens. Even when using a
teleprompter. Who knows? The White House has
retroactively, uh, removed Trump's mention
of Toledo from the official White House transcript
of the speech. So anyway, they're jumping
on the video game bandwagon. And I told you
yesterday, and I will remind you, other countries
have video games. They have atheists, they
have mental illness, they have all the things
that we have that are often blamed for shootings.
Usually they have fewer guns, but they have
no or almost no mass shootings the way that
we do. So this is a planned cordinated talking
point. Distraction. How does Japan have almost
no gun deaths despite having just explosive
video game usage? It is not beyond, uh, w
w we can now say to say it a different way.
It is beyond any doubt that the anti-immigrant
rhetoric of this president is having an effect.
And the debate is over what level of an effect
is it having.
And the right has done two things. One is
they've gotten on this video game bandwagon.
The other is to finally have Donald Trump
mention white supremacy during his speech.
And now Trump has actually said he condemns
white supremacy and white supremacist, which
I commend him for. I do to the extent that
I believe it, but why he not condemn it when
white supremacists endorsed him in 2015, why
did he play coy with it back then and during
2016 in his campaign? What about after Charlottesville?
Why has it taken this long for Trump to finally
say it? We know why. Because he's been resisting
it and now he's saying it because he almost
has no choice. They are up against the wall
here. The shooter mentioned Trump and his
manifesto. Fox News talked about a troubled
young man who had a manifesto, which they
won't tell us the details of as Republicans
all go on national television and radio and
talk about video games.
This is what's called bs and I don't even
think that they realize they're sort of inadvertently
pushing for an anti free speech regulation
of the content of video games, which they're
normally opposed to understand that if the
full conclusion of video games are to blame
is actually grasped as the cause here at the
tail end of that, it's telling video game
makers what can or can't be part of the video
games that they make, which is fundamentally
the opposite of what Republicans have been
advocating for along the lines of free speech
and censorship. All this time, uh, there was
a movement in the 90s about video games and
violence. And to be clear, I really want to
make sure people know this. I don't deny that
there are effects of violence in media to
study. This includes news of crimes on, on
the news about reports of crimes on the news.
Better said violence in movies, violence in
video games. But pretending now that that
connection is violence and video games causes
people to commit mass shootings on the basis
of white nationalist anti-immigrant beliefs.
That's just despicable. And the most shameful
part of it is that they pretend that the point
of the guns that people own is everything
but committing violent acts. Guns are for
hunting, guns are for self-defense, guns are
for the craft of cleaning them and understanding
them their for target practice. Guns are for
everything other than violence. There's no
connection to violence. But the video games,
that's where the violence is. And Video Games
are now a matter of life and death, truly
disgusting. And they may well get away with
it because no heinous act. We know this no
heinous act. We'll get the gun fetishists
to reconsider their point of view. They know
this and that's why they're hopping on this
uh, Video Game Talking Point Bandwagon now
and it may well work.